georges marchais bonsoir la dernière
fois que vous êtes venus ici à antenne 2
en soirée c'était il y a quinze mois à
l'époque vous étiez dans l'opposition
depuis cette époque beaucoup de choses
ont changé vous avez maintenant quatre
ministres communistes au gouvernement et
malgré ça eh bien ça n'a pas suffi à
enrayer le déclin de votre parti si l'on
en croit les résultats des dernières
élections partielles
alors vous disposez d'une heure pour
nous dire la vérité sur ce qui se passe
vraiment à l'intérieur du parti
communiste et pour nous donner votre
point de vue sur les grandes affaires du
monde
vous nous direz aussi comment vous voyez
la deuxième étape de la politique de
françois mitterrand tel qu'il l'a défini
hier au cours de sa conférence de presse
vous avez donc une heure pour nous dire
la vérité vous serez aidé dans cette
tâche et vous serez stimulée par quatre
journalistes et par le public alors
philippe harrouard chef du service
politique d'antenne 2 se trouve asvp où
il reçoit les premiers appels des
téléspectateurs qui peuvent continuer à
appeler sf et 11 787 11 11
mais avant d'aller asvp georges marchais
vous allez devoir affronter trois
journalistes qui sont ici présents dans
ce public qui nous entoure et dont
jusqu'à présent je vous ai caché les
noms y viendrons vous interrogé
successivement dans l'ordre que vous
allez maintenant choisir en tirant au
sort une de ces trois cartes que je vous
tends alors vous lisez vous lisez haute
voix le nom
christine clerc le figaro magazine
alors christine clerc vient s'installer
ici qu'estime clair le figaro magazine
et dès que dès qu'elle sera assise alors
le le chronomètre va partir et alors
je donne deux mots d'explication de
chronomètre va partir maintenant hélas
14 14e minute de chaque quart d'heure
puisque valve vous interroger pendant un
quart d'heure et bien vous aurez un
petit signal sonore comme ces six
voiliers goûter voilà vous saurez que le
quart d'heure se termine a tendu alors
christine clerc au départ top chrono m
bonsoir monsieur marché je crois que
vous arrivez tout de suite d'une grande
manifestation anti israël au cours de
laquelle on a crié des slogans israël or
liban mitterrand complice devrait savoir
si vous êtes d'accord avec ces slogans
et qu'est ce que vous feriez dans ce
conflit et du liban la place du chef de
l'état si vous étiez à sa place tout
d'abord j'ai dis pas ça pour me dérober
je dis ça pour la vérité je n'étais pas
à la manifestation puisque je me
préparais à cette émission mais ce qui
est vrai c'est que ce qui est vrai ça
change rien si j'avais pas une émission
j'aurais participé à la manifestation
le parti communiste soutenait cette
manifestation évidemment il y avait
beaucoup d'organisation il ya des mots
world avec lesquels je ne suis pas
d'accord
par exemple que la politique de monsieur
béguines soit une politique criminelle
ceddat contestable mais dire françois
mitterrand complice c'est pas juste
compte tenu qu'ils hier lors de sa
conférence de presse françois mitterrand
a condamné l'intervention israélienne au
liban
je suis satisfait de cette prise de
position qui marque la fermeté parce que
il est incontestable que la politique de
monsieur begin au moyen orient et en
particulier l'invasion du liban non
seulement peut avoir des conséquences
dramatiques pour l'avenir du moyen
orient c'est à dire l'extension de la
guerre mais je dis que les dom
dramatique pour israël et pour le peuple
israélien lui-même
on ne peut pas provoquer impunément les
peuples comme le fait monsieur begin et
la lutte des palestiniens est une lutte
juste et nous la soutenons
il lui faire la france ils luttent pour
c'est ce qu'a dit également le président
de la république
ils luttent pour la reconnaissance d'un
état ils veulent un état ils veulent une
patrie par conséquent il n'y a pas de
divergence entre la politique du
président de la république et la
politique qui est la note dans cette
affaire je dois dire que nous exigeons
le cessez-le-feu le retrait immédiat des
troupes israéliennes du liban
j'ajoute qu'on ne peut pas demander le
retrait des palestiniens les
palestiniens sont au liban en accord
avec le gouvernement libanais est second
devant les syriens sont également au
liban en accord avec le gouvernement
libanais pardon ses gants de ce retrait
c'est celui des israéliens est ce que
vous êtes aussi satisfait du président
de la république en ce qui concerne les
relations avec les états unis et
l'alliance atlantique vous savez
peut-être que je l'interrogé sur ce
sujet hier et je lui demandait s'il
pensait que c'était à lui que vous
faisiez lisions dimanche au congrès des
jeunesses communistes
lorsque vous avez dénoncé ceux qui
bradent nos usines et ceux qui livrent
la france à reggane il m'a dit qu'il
pensait que non mais que néanmoins vous
faisiez certainement une confusion là
même que moi d'ailleurs parce que vous
aviez tendance à confondre l'alliance
atlantique avec le commandement intégré
à la teinte alors oui ou non êtes vous
satisfait de la politique actuelle de la
france vis-à-vis de l'alliance
atlantique ou considérez vous toujours
que monsieur mitterrand est un
atlantiste flamboyant je pense que vous
avez fait de confusion pour ce qui vous
concerne par rapport à moi discours
divry dimanche à la jeunesse je n'ai pas
dit ce que vous avez dit à la conférence
de presse je vous entendez pas si je les
lui dans l'humanité pourtant mais vous
avez lu avec des lunettes déformantes
parce que j'ai simplement
dit deux choses c'est que d'ailleurs le
président de la république mandat donné
à pts j'ai l'impression que dans la
première partie de son exposé après
votre question il avait sans doute était
troublé par votre question il a pensé
que peut-être vous aviez posé
justement la question et il a corrigé à
la fin à la fin il a dit georges
marchais ne peut pas se tromper sur la
position de la france par rapport à
l'organisation et vous faisiez allusion
mais ça je vais venir alors régler
d'abord la question de l'otan'' d'abord
mais françois mitterrand sait très bien
que georges marchais ne pouvait pas se
tromper sur cette question pourquoi mais
parce que lorsque le général de gaulle a
décidé le retrait de la france de
l'organisation militaire nous
appartenons à l'alliance comme a dit
françois mitterrand c'est juste mais le
retrait l'organisation du directoire de
l'organisation militaire par le général
de gaulle a été approuvée par le parti
communiste français et pour une raison
très simple c'est parce que nous il y
avait des années et des années que nous
luttions pour cet objectif finir à la
question actuelle parce que comme vous
savez je ne dispose que nous luttions
beau cet objectif
et j'ajoute que françois mitterrand a
confirmé hier qu'il était tout à fait
exclu que la france réintègre
l'organisation lo tan organisation
militaire donc par conséquent pas de
confusion alors j'ai parlé effectivement
dans mon discours d'ivry de ceux qui
sont prêts à brader la france aux états
unis commençons par les régates vous
avez parlé des usines est ce que vous
êtes satisfaits de l'augmentation des
investissements américains en france aux
finitions la question parce que je tiens
à vous dire qui gisait il a vu juste
président de la république s'est pas
françois mitterrand objets visés avec
mon discours d'ivry je visais la droite
française prise dans son ensemble
plus précisément plus précisément je
visais chirac le rpr
lecanu et c'est pas la peine d'en parler
tout le monde sait que de calmer tout le
monde sait que le canon est un
atlantisme depuis toujours mais ce qui
est beaucoup plus surprenant aujourd'hui
c'est de voir le rpr qui se réclame du
gaullisme et chirac qui se réclame du
gaullisme est reconnu aujourd'hui
officiellement par monsieur ray
en commettant le chef de l'opposition il
lui a rendu me semble-t-il une visite
symbolique à l'hôtel de ville très
mauvais à mon sens pour chirac il a déjà
une mauvaise image de barques aux yeux
des travailleurs
il soutient qu efficace de l'amérique
bien les ministres communistes aux
dignes et où il y avait bien des
ministres communistes au banquet de
versailles pour accueillir monsieur
reggane non pas nous nous participons
gouvernement ah bon alors vous vous avez
le droit d'accueillir monsieur rigueur
vos ministres parce que vous n'avez pas
accueilli jacques chirac n'a pas le
droit
chirac a tous les droits mais je
considère que la visite que lui a rendue
reagan à l'hôtel de ville et en
désignant comme le chef de l'opposition
et quand on connaît la politique de
reagan au fond c'est la même politique
d'austérité politique de mise en cause
des avantages sociaux des travailleurs
or actuellement chirac qu'est ce qu'il
fait il soutient après avoir soutenu la
direction de citroën
il soutient direction de tableau à
l'assemblée nationale il s'oppose au
droit nouveau des travailleurs par
conséquent on peut dire que pour
reprendre une phrase célèbre de mon ami
jacques duclos reggane chirac blanc
bonnet bonnet blanc
alors j'aimerais revenir à françois
mitterrand et à ce problème de
l'atlantisme quand vous accusiez
autrefois jusqu'à un destin d'être trop
atlantique il y avait il y avait deux
points il y avait la question des
investissements américains en france et
puis avait d'autres parlent tous les
problèmes d'armement vous étiez contre
le fait qu'on ne s'oppose pas à
l'installation des fusées pershing en
france et vous étiez contre la bombe à
neutrons
or depuis que les socialistes sont au
pouvoir les investissements américains
blancs et non seulement ils augmentent
mais on ouvre les portes aux américains
on a fait un colloque pour les patrons
américains au cours duquel lui ministe
sont présentés vous savez comme moi que
ford s'installe à bordeaux que hewlett
packard 2 s'installe à lyon que
rex et rock s'installe à lille en france
bon alors cette politique suivie par les
socialistes n'est plus atlantique alors
que la même politique autrefois été trop
attentistes mais je ne vois pas je ne
vois pas ce qu'il y a dans la politique
extérieure de la france actuellement
qu'ils aillent dans le sens de ce que
vous dites
nous avons conclu avec le parti
socialiste
un accord un accord qui a pris en compte
évidemment des options sur laquelle
françois mitterrand a été élu et cet
accord dans le domaine de la politique
extérieure
il repose sur quoi il repose sur une
série d'idées
tout d'abord la lutte pour la
dissolution des blocs militaires
nous sommes fidèles nous à cette
politique là et je ne vois rien
actuellement dans la politique du
gouvernement français qui aille dans le
sens d'un renforcement des blocs
militaires bien nous sommes mis d'accord
pour une politique de désarmement bien
en troisième lieu
vous êtes sa part est attendue ce soir
prenant sur des rythmes manouches joué
le jeu vous posez votre question frigo
était la réponse
vous parlez de la bombe à neutrons
qu'est ce qu'il a dit le président de la
république hier il a dit nous pouvons
construire la bombe à neutrons
mais il a dit nous n'avons pas décidé de
le faire n'avons pas pris la décision de
le faire nous nous sommes opposés à la
bombe à neutrons may actuellement aucune
décision concernant sa construction
maintenant concernant des
investissements américains en france
évidemment nous critiquons vivement la
politique américaine et mais je crois
que le président de la république que
j'avais d'ailleurs rencontrer avant le
sommet de versailles j'ai constaté de
nombreuses concordance avec lui sur ces
questions là et il ne se faisait pas
trop d'illusions d'ailleurs sur l'issue
du sommet de versailles
nous savons le rôle néfaste que joue le
dos là à 6 francs 28 6 francs 30
nous savons le rôle néfaste que jouent
les taux d'intérêt américains bas en
définitive la politique actuelle que
nous menons nous de relance l'économie
c'est-à-dire de lutte contre le chômage
elles se heurtent complètement à la
politique américaine qui est une
politique de développement du chômage
d'abaissement des droits sociaux des
trains
ailleurs et tout ça pour quoi faire pour
ramener l'inflation à un taux de 7%
par conséquent je pense mais c'est dans
la c'est logique vous êtes en train de
faire un procès à la politique actuelle
du gouvernement français cette politique
là n'est pas celle que vous dites
le président de la république vous avait
prévenu qu'il irait devant dîner
d'ouverture de la session d'automne
oui il m'en avait parlé il n'en avait
parlé et il m'a confirmé que
contrairement sans doute à certaines
spéculations avait il dit elle n'a pas
du tout comme je ne révèle pas un secret
parce que je trouve que dans sa
conférence de presse d'hier il a été
très clair ça n'a pas du tout la
présence du président de la république
hier soir
oui hier soir à bonn au repas offert par
le président de la république de la
république fédérale allemande n'a pas
comme signification
une réintégration de la france dans
l'organisation militaire intégrée de
l'alliance atlantique
nous appartenons à l'alliance pas
d'organisation blick donc sur ce point
aussi vous êtes satisfait du président
de la république
je suis satisfait écoutez racing terre
soyons clairs j'ai dit à l'ats madail
l'élection présidentielle avec un
programme avec une politique
je considère que celle que j'ai proposé
c'était la meilleure elle a reçu l'appui
de quatre millions et demi de français
capillon et demi 5 millions si on prend
en compte des initiatives élection
présidentielle il ya donc des forces
importantes qui ont soutenu mon
programme et ma politique et ses forces
ont été décisives pour battre giscard et
faire élire françois mitterrand cela
étant dit c'est pas ma politique qui a
reçu l'appui de la majorité des français
pendant ces gars comme je suis un
démocrate et que mon parti est un parti
démocratique
nous avons conclu un accord sur la base
de ce que veulent les françaises et des
français et nous travaillons au
gouvernement à la mise en oeuvre de
cette politique là c'est par rapport à
cette politique là qu'il faut se
déterminer en essayant naturellement
d'avancé d'aller de l'avant
alors le soir de l'élection
présidentielle justement vous étiez un
peu déçu évidemment vous avez dit les
électeurs ont voulu faire une expérience
on va faire en sorte que cette
expérience soit pas trop dure pour eux
mais toutes les lignes
aucune réforme dans le programme de
françois mitterrand qui permette de
sortir réellement ce pays de la crise
alors votre jugement d'alors se trouve
infirmé jeudi soir d'élection j'ai pas
dit ça
le soir de l'élection présidentielle non
soir d'élection le que j'ai que j'ai une
opinion sur ce qu'est ce qu'a été ce
qu'est ce qui a été le programme de
françois mitterrand durant la campagne
présidentielle c'est un fait et je les
dis cela étant dit les français ont
choisi et nous avons considéré lorsque
nous avons fait le bilan avec le parti
socialiste entre le parti socialiste et
le parti communiste que dans les 110
propositions de françois mitterrand et
dans mon programme il y avait
suffisamment de convergence pour que
nous participions en france à la gestion
des affaires du pays et
nous essayons de sortir le pays de la
crise
c'est ce à quoi nous sommes attelés
c'est-à-dire résorber le chômage réduire
l'inflation résoudre les grands
problèmes qui sont posés par la crise de
la société à notre peuple alors
évidemment je continue de penser pour ma
part que les solutions que j'ai avancé
durant la campagne électorale et je
pense que l'expérience la pratique le
montrera je pense que certaines de mes
propositions auraient été plus efficaces
je pense d'ailleurs je trouve dans les
propos actuels du président de la
république dans sa conférence de presse
d'hier qui est fidèle à ce qu'a été sa
campagne électorale
mais je trouve des propositions qui me
satisfont pleinement
par exemple j'ai fait un discours à ivry
il ya deux semaines en faisant trois
propositions dans le domaine de
l'économie mais je veux pas développer
parce que je présume
il doit y avoir un journaliste
économique et que ce n'est peut-être pas
votre tâche mais je pense dans ce qui
soutient pas de corps pas de partage
donc j'y vais j'y vais j'y vais donc
dans vous pouvez relire ce discours
d'ivry que j'ai fais pas la jeunesse
lope de semaine à man vous trouverez
trois grandes trois grandes propositions
d'abord je demande une gestion plus
rigoureuse des entreprises et de l'état
lui même
suite mais les questions dans nos
questions j'avais noté ne pas oublier
d'où c'était son anniversaire ce que
j'ai vu vous avez eu 62 ans il ya trois
jours de sept joueurs je vais vous
demander si la pravda vous avez souhaité
votre anniversaire comme elle l'avait
fait il ya deux ans je ne lis pas de
russe et je ne lis pas la pravda et je
n'ai reçu aucun message pour ig en
dehors de prendre l'apéritif à l'issue
du bureau politique nous avons décidé
depuis quelques temps de supprimer les
anniversaires au parti communiste
français nous fêtons anniversaire chez
nous comme le font les travailleurs dans
les entreprises et les employés dans
leur bureau voilà mais j'ai pas sinon
j'ai pas reçu non plus de bons voeux
d'anniversaire du figaro
bon alors on attaque le deuxième quart
d'heure alors vous tiré au sort de
nouveau votre tortionnaires jean
boissonnat à l'expansion jean boissonnat
l'expansion alors jean boissonnat qui
doit être ici dans le public va venir
s'installer et jean je vais vous
demander de vous mettre face d'installer
votre siège face aux micros et non pas
comme l'était christine clerc voilà
déplacer un petit peu votre siège près
dans laxe de monsieur marché comme chez
le dentiste mais c'est le médecin qui
change ici alors deuxième quart d'heure
par dix ces marchés on peut enchaîner
sur ce que vous venez dire que je crois
que ce que vous pensez de la politique
économique du gouvernement intéresse
tous les français pas seulement ceux qui
ont voté pour vous aujourd'hui vous êtes
en charge des affaires de la france pour
vous votre parti mais c'est pareil il ya
quelques temps tout de même qu'aux
parties communes y sont à cesser de
pratiquer le culte de la personnalité
donc une politique a été conduite par ce
gouvernement auquel vous ministre
participe à la obtenu des résultats et
des échecs
hier le président de la république a
fait une sorte de bilan
et il a annoncé une deuxième phase et
dans ce bilan il a reconnu que par
rapport aux objectifs qu'il s'était
fixés notamment en matière de croissance
de la production qui tout de même la
meilleure façon de lutter contre le
chômage
il avait eu des déceptions il a parlé d'
une croissance autour de 2%
les j'imagine que et vous même et lui
espériez que les mesures qui avaient été
prises l'année dernière aboutirait à de
meilleurs résultats
alors je voulais vous demander quel est
votre propre analyse sur les raisons
pour lesquelles ces résultats que vous
espériez l'un et l'autre même si vous
vous auriez pris des mesures un peu
différente comme vous l'avez dit
pourquoi cet échec relatif et compte
tenu de cet échec relatif que faire pour
s'attaquer à ce que vous venez
d'annoncer comme les objectifs je crois
qu'il serait ce de n'importe quel
gouvernement
lutter contre le chômage et lutter
contre la vie chère dans ce pays
quelle est pour vous la raison
principale pour lesquelles vous n'avez
pas pu atteindre les objectifs qu ans
amble votre parti et le parti socialiste
souhaitait atteindre quand ils sont
arrivés au pouvoir
tout d'abord quand vous dites nous
prenons nous sommes en charge le
gouvernement oui nous sommes au
gouvernement nous y sommes en assumant
pleinement et totalement nos
responsabilités mais naturellement dans
la dans la vie dans les limites de notre
propre influence est ce pas nous avons
quatre ministres sur 40 et nous n'allons
pas la majorité à l'assemblée nationale
et à ce que j'ai des quatre ministres
ont fait tout ce qu'ils voulaient faire
ils ont fait ils ont fait leurs devoirs
il n'est pas je ne dis pas ça pour me
dérober je dis ça pense que par
honnêteté n'est ce pas pour les
françaises et des français
on ne peut pas me demander aujourd'hui
d'addenda d'influencé
la politique gouvernementale comme si
nous étions à égalité de force bien
alors sur lui tandis que vous étiez pas
d'accord vous en ayez a évidemment
évidemment évidemment si nous n'étions
pas d'accord nous partirions mais il
n'en est pas question
quand vous présentez de bilan le bilan
que vous faites d'ailleurs le président
de république n'a quand même pas été
aussi dur que vous l'êtes vous même il
n'a pas parlé d'échec le président de la
république
il a parlé de deuxième étape bon et
c'est vrai que par exemple pour ce qui
concerne la croissance que nous
espérions aux environs de 10%
peut-être nous serons plus près
probablement plus près de 2 que de deux
et demi pour cent mais cela ne veut pas
dire que c'est un échec il faut quand
même jugé de la politique économico
sociale autrement que vous ne venez de
faire
pas par exemple le chômage
nous avons réduit de moitié la
progression du chômage
ce qui est vrai c'est que maintenant en
ce moment elle ne se réduit plus bas
mais nous avons quand même réduite de
réduire le rythme le rythme de
progression le rythme de progression
oui je voudrais l'a peut-être si vous le
permettez un simple mot pourrait classer
un débat qui est un des bacs mais
j'aurais bien aimé mais je veux pas vous
en empêcher mais sur le problème du
rythme du chômage parce que souvent nous
mêmes journalistes on a du mal à
s'expliquer à se faire comprendre là
dessus on peut raisonner en pourcentage
et vous avez raison
sous le précédent gouvernement à la fin
le chômage s'est accru de 25% dans une
année avec vous il s'accroît de l'ordre
de 15 donc il s'accroît moins vite en
pourcentage mais je fais ça non mais
attendez je fais observer que
arraisonnement pourcentage n'est pas
convaincant parce qu'un pourcentage ne
s'applique pas aux mêmes chiffres
qu'entre le précédent gouvernement
étaient là la croissance appliquer un
chiffre inférieur
si bien que si l'on compte les chômeurs
non pas en pourcentage mais en nombre
le nombre de chômeurs supplémentaires en
douze mois d'action de du gouvernement
de la gauche
le nombre que d'accroissement est
identique à quelques centaines près à ce
qu'il a été dans les douze mois
précédents je ne m'en réjouis pas et
vous non plus mais c'est simplement pour
dire il faut bien distinguer
et c'est pour éclairer le débat faut pas
qu'il soit votre quart d'heure parce que
sinon il sera pas éclairée du tout alors
je crois que il faut voir les choses
clairement sous giscard pas son
septennat
le chômage a été multiplié par quatre ça
c'est la réalité et avec le gouvernement
actuel nous réduisons nous avons réduit
de moitié
la progression du chômage que vous me
disiez que c'est insuffisant ça j'en
conviens je vais y venir mais n'en ont
pas fait que cela nous allons quand même
avoir une croissance
elle n'est pas ce que nous voulions à
dieu et demi pour cent au moins mais
elle va quand même être légèrement
supérieure à 2 % alors que dans tous les
autres pays c'est le contraire
vous ne savez bien ensuite nous avons
quand même pris un certain nombre de
mesures sociales
je ne développe pas n'ont pas le temps
ensuite nous avons procédé à de grandes
réformes qui nous donne maintenant les
outils pour procéder à la mise en oeuvre
réelle de la politique que nous voulons
faire et qu'est ce que c'est ces outils
c'est en premier lieu la et
nationalisation des secteurs industriel
et bank et crédit
en second lieu c'est la décentralisation
en troisième mieux c'est les pouvoirs
des droits nouveaux que nous donnons aux
travailleurs nous considérons donc que
nous avons maintenant des éléments qui
vont nous permettre de passer à cette
deuxième étape et d'être plus offensif
alors cela étant dit nous avons
rencontré des obstacles
le président en a parlé hier c'est
incontestable
les dégâts sont considérables et vous le
savez très bien en second lieu nous ne
nions pas nous la crise internationale
la crise mondiale et ses retombées
nous disons elle est avant tout
nationale mais c'est vrai que la
politique américaine je l'évoquais tout
à l'heure les taux d'intérêt américains
de dollars au prix il est nous
compliquer les choses
il est un autre élément qu'il faut
prendre en considération c'est
l'attitude du patronat français qui
n'investit pas à la droite française ne
se mène la lutte politique cette droite
qu'est ce que vous croyez la laddh la
droite
c'est ça pouvait gagner de l'argent en
investissant pensez vous qu'elle n'avait
ce tir est pas sûr qu'elle perdrait de
l'argent pour vous faire plaisir
la belle ne perd pas d'argent elle a
choisi une autre voie la droite
française n'investit pas comme elles
devraient le patronat français
il n'investit pas ce que j'ai voulu dire
là c'est que la droite ne se contente
pas de mener la lutte politique contre
le gouvernement de la gauche par des
discours de mr de canut et chirac et
consorts mais je dis que le cnpf
intervient directement contre la volonté
des français contre le gouvernement qui
est en classe par exemple en
investissant pas alors quel est le
résultat de cette politique là par
exemple c'est cela conduit à des
importations abusives des importations
abusives qui met la balance du commerce
extérieur en difficulté il y a donc à la
fois des obstacles qui proviennent de
l'extérieur des retombées de la crise et
des obstacles qui proviennent de
l'intérieur de l'attitude du patronat
français et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je dis parce que c'est vrai
nous ne sommes pas satisfaits et d'où
les communistes je dirais en particulier
qui avons fait du problème de la lutte
contre le chômage et de la lutte pour le
maintien du pouvoir d'achat et contre
l'inflation des objectifs prioritaires
nous ne pouvons effectivement pas être
satisfait de la situation qui existe
maintenant c'est pourquoi je suis j'en
aurai terminé
je suis content d'avoir entendu le
président de la république dit hier et
nous attendons maintenant c'est
l'essence de mon discours d'ivry des
mesures concrètes efficaces
n'est ce pas pour la relance de la
croissance pour les investissements et
quand je vois qu'on va donner 25
milliards au secteur public
je crois que cela va nous permettre
d'avancer dans la bonne voie deux
questions là vous avez parlé des
nationalisations
or le gouvernement a débattu hier du
problème de la sidérurgie
il a décidé d'y investir plus de 20
milliards en quatre ans et non et en
même temps il a reconnu qu'il faudrait
supprimer entre dix et quinze mille
emplois donc le fait de nationaliser le
fait de mettre beaucoup d'argent dans un
secteur comme celui là lourd n'empêche
pas de supprimer des emplois
donc quelles garanties avez-vous que la
nationalisation
de la synergie et d'autres entreprises
vont permettre de créer des emplois
alors que le premier plan que l'on nous
annonce sur la sidérurgie n'annonce pas
des créations
mais les suppressions d'emplois je vous
fais daleba observé x pour ce qui
concerne la sidérurgie que pendant des
années des années sous le précédent
septennat de pompidou genre feront
pidoux sous le septennat de monsieur
giscard d'estaing vraiment c'est un
panier percé que ses patrons de la
sidérurgie
je n'ai pas les chiffres gavin williams
13 milliards de fois au beaucoup plus
que ça a beaucoup du sénat oublie sans
ce n'est pas ce que vous dites ou plus
que ça bien croire qu ait des erreurs de
commises
non non attendez attendez nous avons
nous les précédents gouvernements ont
donné des fonds publics
d'une manière colossale gars or le
gouvernement actuel il se fixe
l'objectif 26 millions de tonnes
26 26 millions de tonnes
c'est notre objectif non c'est
l'objectif des quais actuellement 26
millions de tonnes et pour ce qui
concerne avec les naturellement des
investissements dont vous avez parlé les
lettres publiques dont vous avez parlé
qui est tout à fait normal nous nous
sommes nous ne sommes nous sommes dues
pour l'aide aux entreprises aux
entreprises publiques d'abord c'est
évident mais nous ne sommes pas opposés
à l'aide aux entreprises privées
nous posons une condition aux
entreprises privées c'est que des aides
financières des fonds publics servent à
créer des emplois
alors pour ce qui concerne la sidérurgie
pour le moment il n'est pas question de
15me licenciement comme vous parler non
réductions d'emplois non sens si mauvais
il n'est pas question de 15 millions
pour le non mais vous avouerez 15000
vous avancez des chiffes que sur
lesquels vous ne pouvez pas vous appuyer
sérieusement à partir d'une décision
gouvernementale ce qui est probable
c'est qu'il va y avoir du fait de la
réduction annuelle du travail des
départs en retraite
il est possible qui est la réduction
d'un certain nombre d'emplois mais pas
d'une manière aussi importante que vous
le dites en tout cas ce gouvernement il
va quand même avoir un avantage c'est
qui va relancer la production d'acier
dans notre pays alors que soul 10 car
nous sommes allés à la situation
catastrophique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
oui est-ce que s'il devait y avoir une
dix mille suppressions d'emplois au
cours des quatre prochaines années dans
la sidérurgie vous considéreriez que
vous auriez pu votre place dans ce
gouvernement vous voulez absolument
qu'on porte un nom sommes bien nous
sommes bien en jouant rose hill est pas
question
écoutez il ya une question fondamentale
qui est posée qui déterminera notre
attitude c'est j'ai expliqué doute à
l'heure les choses sont claires pour les
françaises et des français
nous sommes engagés au gouvernement pour
la mise en oeuvre de la politique qui a
été voulu par la majorité des français
il faut pas nous en demander plus à nous
si on voulait plus il fallait voter
davantage pour nous nous agissons dans
le cadre des forces qui nous ont été
données à l'assemblée et au gouvernement
par conséquent nous travaillons
efficacement dans ce sens là la seule
question qui pourrait se poser pour que
nous quittions gouvernement là où la
question pourrait se poser c'est dans
l'hypothèse où le président de la
république et où le parti socialiste ne
tiendrait pas le cap sur la politique
voulue par les français le 10 mai c'est
seulement là qui pourraient se poser une
question
or je vous fait observer que
contrairement aux spéculations de la
presse et des journalistes ne veut pas
de vous pas de vous j'ai dit la presse
et les journalistes
mais vous le savez qu'il ya eu un débat
après à partir des propos de tel ou tel
ministre et cetera
le président de la république hier a
confirmé le cap
c'est à dire le cap c'est le 10 mai et
nous nous travaillons à partir de la
politique voulue par les françaises et
les français de 10 mais nous avons un
accord sur cette balle tant que nous
resterons sur ce chemin da et tout ce
que nous ferons pour aller plus avant
dans cette voie là aura l'appui et le
soutien du parti communiste fort mais le
test le cap c'est bien le cap c'est un
objectif politique globale mais ça ce
test à des résultats concrets ça se
mesure des travailleurs et compte leur
pouvoir d'achat la fin du mois il
regarde s'il ya des emplois nouveaux
l'avicca carte si la vie chère et moins
fort
en raison d'un sauna c'est pourquoi par
exemple la semaine dernière j'ai je
trouve dans les propos du président de
la république comme un écho à ce que
j'ai dit moi même c'est à dire
contentant de même sens jeudi plus de
rigueur dans la gestion des entreprises
et compris au niveau de l'état
c'est-à-dire en finir avec les gâchis
que nous connaissons et cetera je passe
un exemple deuxièmement coûté détaillé
de lachy financiers ils sont énormes
vous avez des entreprises on continue
ici à casser les entreprises ici pour
investir à l'étranger je pourrais vous
citer des dizaines d'exemples offrez
vous et vous en connaissez autant que
moi
en 11 ans 1 deuxièmement attendait non
je vais au bout de mon isolement est ce
que renault a raison d'investir aux
états unis
renault a raison d'investir aux états
unis dans la mesure dans la mesure où ça
ne conduit pas à atténuer en quoi que ce
soit le rôle que doit jouer cette
entreprise nationale en france l'argent
qu'ils attendent et on a une minute
maman deuxième mon deuxième propos c'est
la reconquête du marché intérieur donc
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure avec récit
est mon troisième propos c'est de dire
il faut plus de justice sociale c'est
pourquoi nous nous demandons l'élément
du pouvoir d'achat des petits et moyens
solaire le maintien du pouvoir d'achat
pour tous les salariés qui sont couverts
par des conventions collectives
mais en même temps ni le monde en
quelques chiffres nous ne fixons pas de
chiffres nous dit tous les salariés
couverts par les conventions collectives
n'ont pas fixé le chief et en troisième
mais nous demandons ensuite les impôts
sur les hauts revenus soit relevé de la
même façon qu'il faut revoir l'assiette
pour les impôts des grandes sociétés
est ce que dans ces camps voyez nous
faisons des propositions un dernier mot
est ce que vous êtes pour ou contre le
blocage des prix bas je pense qu'il
faudra y venir
quand vous dites qu'en dites vous êtes
pour la solidarité vous approuvez le
président de république quand il a dit
hier que tout le monde devrait payer pas
seulement les riches à mais faut
s'entendre là-dessus
non tout le monde devra payer vous
voulez quand même pas demander un
smicard de payer vous voulez pas
demander à un ouvrier professionnel
qualifié
kiki qui gagne 458 même cinq cent mille
anciens francs par mois de payer ce ne
sont pas
les petits et moyens salaires qui
doivent payer ceux qui doivent payer
c'est les hauts revenus c'est pourquoi
je j'ai dit et je hais je maintiens et
je maintiens maintien du pouvoir d'achat
pour les salariés couverts par la
convention collective ou les statuts
mais pas pour les autres et jeudi
augmenter les impôts pour les hauts
revenus et l'assiette pour revoir
l'assiette pour les sociétés d'accord
pour que les fonctionnaires participe au
financement de l'assurance chômage
non je suis pas d'accord voilà votre
troisième match d'accord mais nous
faisons d'autres propositions
s'il y en avait le temps mes
propositions ils sont sérieuses mais
peut-être nous allons voir avec les
accords le troisième quart d'heure
michel cardoze alors ça je crois que je
crois qu'on doit un mot d'explication
des spectateurs quand même je vais très
bien je crois qu'on doit un mot de la
mode explication quand même aux
téléspectateurs il faut quand même dire
michel il faut quand même bien non mais
rassurez vous je vous accorderez la
prolongation il faut quand même dire aux
téléspectateurs que michel cardoze a
passé dix ans à l'humanité et que c'est
quand même la première fois
georges marchais que vous êtes interrogé
dans cette maison par un journaliste de
l'audiovisuel communiste c'est la
première fois ces revient pas mais pas
seulement à cette maison en général la
révision c'est quand même c'est quand
même un événement je crois qu'il fallait
le dire alors michel je suis parti ça
veut dire que je suis prêt à tout et
j'ai pensé à tout sauf à ça alors alors
mérite l'origine pensé pour vous ça va
être original première question georges
marchais il ya un mois sur france inter
vous avez dit il est encore trop tôt
pour dresser un bilan tout à l'heure ça
m'a beaucoup frappé vous avez repris le
bilan dressé hier par françois
mitterrand en dix ans chaque fois nous
c'est à dire en n'endosse en tout le
bilan dressé par françois mitterrand est
revenu à plusieurs reprises
vous avez dit à plusieurs reprises que
vous étiez content vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises
nous sommes bien alors est-ce que je
dois déceler ce que les journalistes
doivent déceler la une espèce de
modifications dans votre attitude que
vous abandonnez cette sorte de distance
que vous aviez me semble-t-il vis-à-vis
des résultats de la gauche distance qui
risquait à mon avis d'encourager un peu
de scepticisme
de défiance notamment dans l'électorat
communiste non le jeu continue de penser
qu'il est tôt pour faire un bilan
la majorité est en place législatives
est en place pour cinq ans la majorité
présidentielle pouces 7 ans le programme
de françois mitterrand porte sur sept
ans nous sommes à la fin de la première
année
il est donc trop tôt pour dresser un
bilan d'ensemble
cependant nous pouvons déjà quand même
porté une appréciation et c'est ce que
je viens nous de faire doute à l'heure
avec jean boissonnat ne maintenant pas
au problème de la croissance économique
mais examinons aussi d autres aspects de
la politique qui a été mise en oeuvre
alors quand je dis nous nous sentons
bien tout à l'heure nous nous sentons
bien dans notre position de membre du
gouvernement
nos autorités voilà je vais m'expliquer
c'est très important cette question on
nous présente toujours comme un parti
d'opposition
au fond le parti communiste français
sera à particules par vos questions
devraient toute sa vie est dans
l'opposition
je dis non je dis non et nous disons non
le parti communiste français a aussi
vocation à gouverner et à gérer les
affaires du pays et je crois que nos
ministres sont la démonstration aux
côtés de leurs collègues évidemment mais
il faut la démonstration de leurs
aptitudes et de leurs capacités
ils se connaissent bien tous les
communistes pense comme ça aujourd'hui
non non c'est clair molde est-ce qu'on
peut à la fois lutter et gouverner il
faut faire les deux la grèce on peut pas
poser la question est-ce qu'il faut il
faut faire les deux mais ma question
était est ce que tous les communistes
sont d'accord et au delà des communistes
les électeurs comme unis sont d'accord
pour que ce parti ait pris la décision
d'être dans ce gouvernement n'a elles
sont pas tous d'accord et là je
m'explique et à tous je viens de
terminer sur la première question parce
que j'ai pas perdu le fil g m nous
sommes bien donc au gouvernement dans
l'esprit que je viens de dire
maintenant nous sommes contents non non
on va dire nous sommes contents on est
satisfait on saute de joie et on chante
tous les soirs non nous savons qu'il ya
près de deux millions de chômeurs 2
millions de chômeurs il reste une
inflation à 12 et demi pourcent trop
élevé il ya beaucoup de problèmes qui
n'ont pas été résolues et je sais que il
y a dans l'opinion publique
des hommes et des femmes qui ont voté
pour le changement à 2
mais et qui exprime une certaine
déception parfois du mécontentement
je ne sais ça ça ne veut pas dire que
ces gens là veulent revenir à giscard il
n'en est pas question
mais ils ne sont pas satisfaits on vient
donc il faut travailler aller de l'avant
dans l'esprit de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure
alors maintenant revenons en à nos
communistes là
globalement si je puis dire dans sa base
le parti communiste naturellement
approuve la participation des
communistes au gouvernement
sinon nous voulons avoir un congrès
sinon ça se saurait il est concret il ya
une partie des communistes qui
n'appauvrit le congé aurait décidé eh
bien oui il y à des communistes
ces deux stades ailleurs que nous avons
beaucoup parlé lors de la session notre
comité central à sac la panne ou quand
j'ai dit nous avons nous avons des
problèmes
pourquoi le cacher nous avons des
problèmes lesquels précis lors beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes
d'abord il ya des problèmes qui touchent
à cette question immédiate que vous
venez de poser tout à l'heure à savoir
il se sentait mieux
dans l'opposition il se sentait mieux
quand
l'activité leur propre activité celle de
leur organisation était réduite à la
contestation plus facile d'être contre
que d'être pour quelque chose c'est
évident c'est plus facile
tandis que là il faut à la fois soutenir
une politique donnée et organiser les
luttes pour avoir l'appui des
travailleurs pour vaincre les
résistances que nous rencontrons en
particulier dans les entreprises de la
part du patronat revient bien ça se
passe concrètement ballack si vous aviez
un conseil à donner à des communistes ce
soir comment ça se passe concrètement
pour un communiste être à la fois dans
la majorité et en même temps organiser
la lutte contre le patronat qu'ils
soient publics ou privés au fond mais je
tiendrai je tiendrai le langage un
langage simple serait pas beaucoup de
temps je dirais c'est vrai que les
choses ne vont pas aussi vite que vous
le voulez que vous l'expérience
j'ajouterai même y compris pour des
communistes et des électeurs communistes
votre désillusion aujourd'hui est à la
hauteur de vos illusions d'hier c'est
beaucoup plus difficile que vous ne le
pensiez c'est pas parce que vous est-ce
que ses partenaires
non il suffira de conquérir le pouvoir
pour que la société soit changée comment
est-ce que c'est pas parce que vous leur
avez trop longtemps j'avais dit ça moi
en irak ont jamais dit ça j'ai jamais
dit ça justement je ne reproche que je
fais la constitution actuelle c'est
quand il ya des élections qu'elles
soient présidentielle législatives ou
autre c'est que ces élections conduisent
toujours à on est pour ou on est content
mais on n'appelle pas les françaises et
des français à réfléchir et à se
déterminer en fonction d'une politique
en fonction d'un programme en fonction
des mesures nécessaires pour sortir le
pays de la crise alors qu'est ce que je
dis aux communistes de la qui qui qui
qui se posent des questions qui passe
peut-être on était mieux peut-être
faudrait mieux retourné dans la majorité
dans l'opposition qui pensent même au
regard au vu des élections partielles
mais ça ne nous rapporte pas on ne gagne
pas comme si on pouvait remonter comme
ça tout de suite mécaniquement notre
influence je le dis réfléchi ses
camarades
réfléchissez et ce qu'il faut revenir à
la politique de jyske à celle qui a
conduit qu'à jeté le pays dans la
catastrophe
ou est-ce qu'il faut tenir
notre place dans cette majorité là et
faire ensemble tout ce que nous pouvons
faire pour aller de l'avant dans la voie
de la solution de la crise mais si on
pose la question comme ça la réponse
elle va de soi si vous la poser aux
françaises et aux français qui ont voté
à gauche évidemment pas la droite
la réponse va de soi ils disent vous
devez rester au gouvernement
et vous devez continuer d'agir
efficacement pour résoudre des problèmes
posés alors dans les raisons qui font
qu'il ya une petite partie des
communistes difficile à évaluer qui est
un peu gêné aux entournures en ce moment
est-ce que parmi ces raisons est ce
qu'il n'ya pas qui réside dans la
politique du parti communiste disons
dans les trois dernières années
c'est ce que j'avais envie de tout à
l'heure parce qu'il n'y a pas seulement
la question de la participation au
gouvernement à vous savez évidemment on
pas le temps ici d'ailleurs j'ai fait un
rapport de cinq heures au congrès pour
expliquer ça donc on peut pas le traiter
en un quart d'heure mais au fond on peut
résumer la façon suivante
depuis 1968 avec valve décrocher le
parti communiste français a abordé une
mutation profonde je préfère une autre
parti communiste n'a pas un problème
n'est pas de faire un autre parti
communiste
le problème qui a été qui est posée
depuis 68 qui a été posée par waldeck et
que nous avons conduit à bien avec le
24e congrès ça c'est mon opinion
profonde et ses opinions se dit
d'ailleurs une écrasante majorité des
membres du parti
ça a été quoi ça a été de définir une
stratégie conforme à notre époque est
conforme à ce que veulent les françaises
et les français
or ce que rappelle construire une
société socialiste parce que c'est ça la
réponse à la crise que nous connaissons
actuellement une société socialiste à la
française et par une voie démocratique
évidemment nous sommes loin de l'oeuvre
de l'époque où les notes c'est pas une
critique parce que sans doute apte il
fallu passer par par là
peut-être y at-il eu aussi des erreurs
ça laisse aux historiens
ils régleront cette question mais c'est
vrai que c'est une situation
fondamentalement différente avec
l'époque où il avait un modèle en vue il
voyait le modèle soviétique comme si on
pouvait construire chez nous une société
socialiste calqué sur ce qu'est le
socialisme en sûrs c'est aujourd'hui
c'est fini c'est sûr regard sur le
modèle c'est fini absolument nous tirons
d'abord
y'a pas un modèle il ya il ya une grande
diversité de société socialiste qui se
construisent qui sont en construction et
bien de ces expériences là sans doute
des enseignements peuvent être tirés
mais de toute façon il est exclu deux
soeurs de construire chez nous une
société socialiste qui ne reposerait pas
fondamentalement sur ce qu'est la france
et ce que sont les français
il ne s'agit même pas d'habiller un type
de société socialiste de quelques
particularités nationales
c'est beaucoup plus profond que cela au
fond parti communiste français
nous sommes le prolongement du mouvement
ouvrier du vieux parti ouvrier du parti
communiste né en 1920 et en 1982 nous
sommes le parti communiste qui est
capable d'apporter la réponse claire et
9 à la question que se posent les
travailleurs et en particulier la
jeunesse quelle société faut-il à la
france aujourd'hui notre congrès donc si
je comprends bien vous alors c'est pour
ça que j'ai rendu compte que vous
reprenez votre compte ce qui a été dit
c'est un c mois dernier à savoir que le
parti communiste et le parti socialiste
sont issus d'un même tronc commun
vous reprenez votre compte je change de
plage il ya des greffes d'os a mais
c'est une question sur laquelle j'ai
réfléchi et j'ai l'intention d'écrire je
pense qu'en 1920 mais il fallait rang
c'est vrai qu'il fallait rompre avec le
réformiste avec le vieux le vieux parti
le contre mais sans doute d'autant notre
parti nous est né de la majorité du
parti socialiste sans doute n'avons pas
pris suffisamment en compte la qui
jaurès guesde jugement réclame alors je
reviens je change de plage il ya des
greffes d'os en ce moment dans
l'automobile où sont engagés presse
exclusivement les projets dits presque
exclusivement les ouvriers immigrés sous
le regard les uns approbateurs les
autres m
et puis certains aussi hostile des
ouvriers français alors qu'est ce que ça
donne à penser au secrétaire général du
parti communiste
7 c'est grève et cette apparente
division enfin en tout cas pas grande
unité de la classe ouvrière face au nahd
je crois que ces grèves que nous avons
connue d'abord chez citroën est
maintenant chez talbot s expriment elles
ont un tronc commun à fond commun alain
c'est cette une protestation
contre des formes d'exploitation des
conditions de travail inhumaines et
contre le fait que dans ces entreprises
il ya un absence totale de liberté
syndicale et de démocratie
hélas au fond pour ces travailleurs là
il vient d'y avoir un espèce de doha de
révélateur d'un seul coup la victoire du
10 mai et ils se disent maintenant les
conditions existent pour que nous
changions ça c'est ça le fond de du
mouvement que nous connaissons
actuellement est que nous soutenons
alors vous dites ça touche surtout des
travailleurs immigrés et oui parce que
par seulement 1 il ya aussi des
travailleurs français
mais les travailleurs immigrés c'est
l'écrasante majorité sur les chaînes
notamment dans les entreprises
d'automobiles c'est ce qui explique que
vous savez il ya 83 nationalité dans ce
pays c'est tout à fait vrai mais il ya
quand même un petit problème en dehors
de l'aide de la question de la csl par
exemple à talbot est aussi un citron il
ya quand même un petit problème entre
semble-t-il la main d'oeuvre française
et la main d'oeuvre immigrée
on ne voit pas les ouvriers
professionnels français par exemple se
jeter comme on dit dans le jargon
communiste dans la lutte aux côtés des
ouvriers immigrés en ce moment les
ouvriers professionnels revendiquait il
s'agissait et ils soutiennent ces luttes
mais c'est vrai que dans les entreprises
il ya ya ya ya des revendications et des
situations tellement différentes que les
revendications ne sont pas de même
nature bien nous change encore favorable
à une extension des droits civiques des
travailleurs immigrés par exemple qui
vote pour les élections municipales
non nous sommes pas fabre à nous nous
pensons que des travailleurs immigrés
peuvent être associés évidemment dans
des communes où ils vivront peut les
consulter on peut trouver des formes etc
mais nous ne sommes pas favorables au
vote des travailleurs immigrés
d'ailleurs nous nous constatons que les
partis de gauche des pays exportateurs
de madame ils sont absolument opposé
pour une raison bien compréhensible
c'est faire voter les travailleurs
immigrés ça veut dire les intégrer à la
société française ces gens là ce sont
des victimes du capitalisme et il aspire
à retourner dans leur pays ne veulent
pas est intégré certains soient très
différents je change encore de plage
vous appelé à une manifestation le 20
juin pour le désarmement de remarques à
vous soumettre
première remarque le texte de l'appel on
peut le considérer comme un peu floue un
peu vague
peut-être tout le monde peut signer ou
presque en tout cas il ne fait pas
allusion nommément ni oss vin ni au
pershing
vous allez nous dire si vous si vous
avez une position précise là dessus la
deuxième remarque c'est que je ne vois
pas dans la liste des signatures qui est
publié presque quotidiennement dans
l'humanité de dirigeants du parti
socialiste
est-ce que vous avez contacté le parti
socialiste à ce sujet qu'est ce qu'il
vous a répondu sur cette question alors
l'allemagne
le mot d'ordre les mots d'ordre c'est
simple démo donne nous nous disons il
faut arrêter la course aux armements
c'est démentiel faut être plus précis
peut-être sans le sens de l'europe
non c'est démentiel la course aux
armements c'est démentiel
j'avais j'avais tout à l'heure j'ai vu
ça dans la presse
j'ai quand même pris des notes parce que
voilà reagan qui vient de déclarer à
londres il faut engager une croisade
pour la liberté
il faut renvoyer les marci ce délit
nisme au tad sand de l'histoire bon eh
bien ce même reagan un budget militaire
qui était de 180 milliards en 80 222 en
82 et 367 en 1986 et bien faut pas
oublier que les états unis c'est un pays
qui possède l arme atomique et qu'il l'a
utilisé à hiroshima
par conséquent la menace d'un conflit
nucléaire existe il faut donc mettre un
terme à la course aux armements
alors on nous allons nous a fait aurions
nous fait les pires procès nous sommes
les agents de moscou évidemment il
supplie contenant nous nous déterminent
je dis pas par rapport à vous nous nous
déterminons pas par rapport à l'union
soviétique
nous disons il faut arrêter la course
aux armements et il faut pas se
contenter de jeu
les armements au niveau où elles sont
actuellement il faut commencer à prendre
des mesures de désarmement alors cela
étant dit nous n'avons aucune illusion
la voix du de la route qui conduira au
désarmement est une route longue qui va
demander beaucoup d'efforts en tout cas
qu'il va demander c'est une certitude
l'intervention des papes l'intervention
des matches il faut qu'on traîne des
fauteurs de guerre
les fabricants d'armement a accepté
cette politique nouvelle alors donc nous
nous sommes toutes les ss 20 et nous
sommes contre les piercings et des
crises c'est clair ça nous nous sommes
pour le désarmement dans l' équilibre
des forces
nous sommes opposés à ce qu'un pays quel
qu'il soit que ce soit lui ou que ce
soit les états unis où que ce soit la
france puisse disposer d'une supériorité
militaire sur les autres donc nous
sommes pour le désarmement dans l'
équilibre dans la sécurité des états
autrement dit moi vous savez vous dire
vu aller beaucoup plus loin vous ne le
pensez je suis d'accord avec avec kenzy
aux états unis avec les mots d'ordre de
mcnamara je suis d'accord avec les mots
d'ordre du des militants du spd en
allemagne des iu sens de la jeunesse
socialiste allemande je suis d'accord
avec les chrétiens à travers le monde je
suis d'accord avec les forces en
belgique en ondes qui soudait et en
france attendait ce qui sous des baux
d'ordre qui sous des formes les plus
diverses pose un problème simple qu'il
faut commencer à désarmer dans la
sécurité
voilà notre politique alors en france il
ya cent personnalités pour 9h d'opinion
très très diverses est depuis en a
beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs qui
appellent à une manifestation
les mots d'ordre ce sont ces
personnalités qui les ont établi elle
même
ce sont des mots d'ordre st ce sont les
mots d'ordre qui peuvent rassembler tout
le monde
moi je suis profondément convaincu que
dans ce pays même des gens de droite ne
veulent pas la guerre
enfin une guerre atomique c'est la
catastrophe pour l'humanité les dépenses
d'armement quand chaque jour y attend
d'eux
d'hommes de femmes d'enfants qui meurent
de faim dans le monde
c'est une honte par conséquent jeudi qu'
il faut se rassembler sur le mode horde
le plus bas possible dès l'instant dès
l'instant où cela constitue un petit pas
vers le désarmement il faut mettre le
pied dans ce pas là c'est la politique
des communistes c'est pourquoi nous nous
retrouvons et nous nous retrouverons
avec tout ce même ceux qui sont anti
communistes qui sont contre le
socialisme vous êtes pour la paix nous
sommes fondamentalement pour la paix
nous sommes nés de la guerre notre parti
communiste donc nous sommes pour la paix
et nous voulons agir alors de parti
socialiste nous avons proposé au parti
socialiste de d'agir avec nous dont il
appelle pas pour cette manifestation là
il ya des socialistes qui sont
signataires parmi les personnalités
je m'en félicite nous avons proposé
il paraît que le parti socialiste va
nous proposer une discussion sur cette
question de la paix je m'en félicite et
je dis nous pouvons très facilement
tomber
arrivés plus tôt à un accord parce que
je répète nous l'ont rappelé bon alors
michel cardoze vous rester là et nous
allons aspp alors philippe harrouard oui
c'est bien que des questions
écoutez depuis 20h le standard est
quasiment bloqué en permanence c'est
vous dire le nombre de questions dans
lesquelles nous nageons ya des sujets
très divers
je commence tout eu tort deux petites
questions monsieur marchait etes-vous en
bonne santé demande monsieur meunier de
toulouse et un autre téléspectateurs de
toulouse demande quand allez vous
prendre votre retraite
premièrement je suis dans en une en
excellente santé
samedi dernier j'ai fait 70 km en vélo
des journalistes m'ont rencontré
d'ailleurs ils ont pu constater que
j'avais la fin je suis pas prêt à
bationo dans le tour de france c'est
clair mais parfaite santé la retraite
jeudi pense absolument pas je pense à la
lutte politique et je pense surtout à
l'effort nécessaire pour remonter
l'influencent de notre parti monsieur
marché un très grand nombre de questions
concernant le sommet de versailles avec
ce thème que pensez-vous des fastes de
versailles alors qu'il ya tant de
chômage quelle aurait été la réaction de
monsieur marchait si giscard avait
organisé les festivités de versailles
n'est-il pas indécent de voir tout
l'argent qui a été dépensé à versailles
il y en a beaucoup d'autres
ouais et goûter je vois bien d'où je
vois d'où d'où viennent les caisses
cette question tout d'abord jusqu'à si
on fait des comptes de ce qu'il a
dépensé inutilement au service du grand
capital bien nous sommes loin de contre
cela étant dit bon et bien j'étais pas
organisateur mois de la réception de
versailles et enfin la france a
accueilli des chefs d'états de
différentes nations ont déjà accueilli
dans un cadre donné bon bah c'est il
faut faire ces choses alors il peut être
on a pu faire un peu moi peut-être à la
place de françois mitterrand sdrif
choisi quel cadre j'ai pas pensé
moi je me mets à la place mme je suis je
suis pas un rêveur mois au sèche linge
et alisha matérialiste philippe
harrouard toujours concernant
versailleux plusieurs téléspectateurs
nous disons meeting des jeunesses
communistes marché a traité reggane
d'assassins dans le même temps le
ministre fiterman déjeuner avec regan
comment monsieur marche explique cela
monsieur fiterman n'aurait pas dû aller
crier contre vegan le samedi est allé en
smoking dimanche à versailles pose une
autre question c'est un autre débat
politique
charles fiterman charles fiterman
ministre d'état il a été invité à
versailles
et il a bien fait d'y aller moi aussi
j'étais invité je m'en suis excusé
auprès du président de la république qui
m'a fort bien compris parce que j'étais
à ivry avec la jeunesse et je ne pouvais
pas et à cette heure à versailles et je
me suis félicité que le président de la
république accepte que mon camarade de
andré lajoinie secrétaires du parti et
président du groupe me représente par
conséquent il était juste que les
communistes soient
à versailles question monsieur marché
qui nous a souvent été posée je la
résume par cette question de monsieur
rohart de montville hier dans la somme
comment se fait-il que monsieur marchait
soit contre la participation des
fonctionnaires à l'effort national
ah ah mais ben écoutez je suis contre le
tout d'abord il faut quand même bien
voir il s'agit de la situation de
l'unedic assurance chômage
c'est ça la question qui est qui et qui
est posée alors on dit sous prétexte que
les fonctionnaires ont la garde à
garantie de l'emploi
ils doivent participer ils sont la
garantie de l'emploi mais le petit
postier qui a le smic ou à peine plus
que le smic
il faut qu'il participe lui à la
solidarité
moi j'ai dire les directeurs généraux
moi j'ai dit non alors que l'on examine
que l'on examine qu'à partir d'un
certain niveau de salaire
il y ait une participation ça je ne suis
pas opposé mais
en principe la décision que tous les
fonctionnaires sous prétexte qu'on est
fonctionnaire on doit cotiser pour
résoudre un problème que l'on peut
résoudre par d'autres moyens
il ya des hauts revenus qui qu'il faut
frapper il ya des dépenses excessives
que l'on peut réduire
gg des propositions nous n'avons pas de
temps maintenant mais je vais dépublié
j'ai des propositions qui permettraient
tout de suite de trouver 12 milliards
c'est pas négligeable
il ya tant de 7 milliards de trouve oui
mais mais mais il faut il faut trouver
mais d'abord fort et violent chômage
aussi effectivement c'est plus facile à
dire qu'à faire mais votre question oui
nous avons eu énormément de questions
sur les conflits sociaux vous en avait
déjà parlé il y en a une que je trouve
très intéressante
depuis la victoire de la gauche les
luttes de classes au sein des
entreprises sont-elles menées de manière
différente
c'est un magasinier qui nous pose cette
question depuis depuis la victoire de la
gauche les luttes de place pour ça des
entreprises sont celles menées de
manière différente je veux même bien au
delà des entreprises j'ai dit j'ai dit
que la victoire du 10 mai n'avait pas
supprimé
la lutte des classes en france ça vous
savez c'est comme karl marx est mort
nous avons entendu ça et nous entendons
toujours sa karl marx il est bien vivant
évidemment beaucoup de choses ont changé
et d'évoquer tout à l'heure mais la
lutte de classe elle n'a pas disparu
avec la victoire du 10 mai et dans les
entreprises
l'expérience montre que les travailleurs
s'ils n'agissent pas il n'arrive pas à
imposer au patronat même certaines
décisions gouvernementales
les 39 heures par exemple sans
diminution de salaire il a fallu la
lutte des travailleurs pour l'imposer et
croyez moi les droits nouveaux que les
travailleurs vont conquérir dont nous
discutons en ce moment à l'assemblée
nationale la loi ne suffira pas il
faudra à l'imposer à un patronat qui est
un patronat rétrograde vous le savez
vous êtes satisfait des 39 heures vous
estimez que ça crée des emplois c'est
une étape
c'est une étape des 39 heures monsieur
marché à la suite des conflits chez
talbot chez citroën on nous pose
énormément de questions concernant les
immigrés et on vous pose la question
souvent très brutalement en dix ans
lorsque l'on parle de tant de chômeurs
en france monsieur marché trouve qu il
normal que nous ayons que nous offrions
tant d'emplois aux immigrés on nous
demande de temps en temps même si on ne
devrait pas les renvoyer chez eux ces
plaisanteries ça pas de poser cette
question au parti communiste français le
parti communiste français il nous avons
nous avons chez nous les travailleurs
immigrés qui à l'époque où l'économie
française marchait bien ont contribué
d'une manière importante à croître les
richesses de la france
ces travailleurs immigrés ils sentent
ici quand il ya le chômage
on ne peut pas dire envoyer chez eux on
peut pas dire aux immigrés c'est bien
que vous soyez chez nous et que vous
travaillez quand les choses vont mais
quand les choses ne vont plus alors on
vous renvoie chez vous nous disons ces
travailleurs immigrés ils doivent ici
bénéficier des mêmes avantages
quand ils sont au chômage que les autres
mais il ya longtemps que nous avons dit
nous il faut arrêter l'arrivée de la
main d'oeuvre immigrée
quand le chômage a commencé à
s'accroître dans des proportions aussi
considérable or à l'époque on nous a
traités de racistes nous avions raison
nous avons toujours dit il faut pas
faire venir des travailleurs émigrés
pour en faire des chômeurs bras nous
avons donc une politique claire dans
cette affaire monsieur marché la hausse
du prix de l'essence nous permet de vous
poser beaucoup de questions alors par
exemple celle ci avant que le parti
communiste soit dans le gouvernement
monsieur marcher parler toujours des
multinationales pétrolières françaises
qui faisaient des bénéfices et
maintenant on entend plus parler
et puis cette autre question pourquoi
avoir laissé augmenté l'essence alors
que vous étiez content avec l'autre
gouvernement et puis j'ai énormément de
fiches sur ce même thème je n'ai pas
changé d'opinion sur les problèmes de
l'essence pas changé d'opinion sur un
fameux débat que j'ai eu avec fourcade
ce que j'ai dit à l'époque reste
entièrement valable et je considère
effectivement et je né dis et je pense
d'ailleurs que je ne suis pas le seul à
penser ainsi à gauche que certaines
décisions concernant d'essence n'était
pas très bienvenu on peut
on peut ne pas augmenter je sais bien
que maintenant avec le dollar
la hausse constante du dollar ça pose
problème mais vous savez les profits que
réalisent les sociétés pétrolières les
multinationales ces profils à res et
d'autres pas les taxes sont très
importantes sur l'essence par conséquent
je dis que nous avons nous atteignons
maintenant un seuil
il faut arrêter on ne peut pas continuer
d'augmenter le prix de l'essence a aura
des conséquences obligatoire sur
l'industrie automobile française
notamment
alors un dernier retour svp monsieur
marchait beaucoup de téléspectateurs
veulent vous entendre parler visiblement
de l'école libre il vous pose la
question que pensez vous des écoliers
quelle est votre position face au
problème de la liberté d'enseignement
que la position du fait ses vis-à-vis
des lois debré et guermeur etc
nous sommes pour un grand service public
laïque
gratuit voilà la position qui est la
nôtre est prêt et naturellement
pluraliste mais cela ne ne signifie pas
évidemment que nous entendons nous
opposer à ce que des gens qui veulent
envoyer leurs enfants à l'école libre
puisse le faire
nous sommes pour la liberté mais nous
sommes pour un grand service laïque
public gratuit et pluraliste et diana
sedan mais je suis bien content vous me
posiez cette question j'en ai beaucoup
parlé dimanche
en m'adressant à la jeunesse je dis et
je le dis aux dirigeants de la
fédération d'éducation nationale que
j'ai reçue lundi
jeudi la jeunesse les parents les
enseignants sont tous placés devant un
grand problème de l'école connaît une
crise profonde
on ne peut pas être satisfait de
l'enseignement qui est donné aujourd'hui
à nos enfants
d'une part il ne correspond pas aux
progrès scientifiques et techniques aux
exigeantes de la société et d'autres
fois il ne correspond pas à ce que veut
et souhaite la jeunesse par conséquent
je dis il faut réformer fondamentalement
il faut une mutation profonde du système
d'enseignement français
et ça concerne tout le monde ça concerne
l enseignant je répète mais aussi des
parents et les jeunes les jeunes ils
veulent tête consultés ils ont raison
moi je les soutiens quand j'ai vu votre
geste philippe harrouard thunder bay ont
j'ai une dernière question elle n'est
pas encore tout à fait d'actualité c'est
un peu comme dans le film c'est arrivé
demain mais je vous la pose monsieur
marché qu'elle de quel côté penche
serait votre coeur si la coupe du monde
était un match prs france france
évidemment france évidemment
voilà donc j'aurai ce n est nullement
contradictoire si on veut opposer le
fait que que le communiste que je suis
n'oublie pas que la révolution a
commencé en union soviétique en 1917 que
je n'oublie pas le rose
j'ai rappelé dimanche dernier cas jouer
l'union soviétique dans l'écrasement dit
lyrisme les 20 millions de morts moi je
suis pour la belle et bonne alias dans
le respect de l'indépendance de chaque
pays dans l'intérêt mutuel
je n'oublie pas ces choses là mais cela
étant dit je suis un bon français et sur
le terrain de football et je vais
d'ailleurs y aller à madrid évidemment
s'il y avait une telle finale j'y serai
croyez moi
l'équipe de france aura mon appui sans
chauvinisme parce que là je me place sur
le plan sportif je suis pour que le
meilleur gagne
je souhaite qu'en tout cas en
l'occurrence le meilleur il soit
français je serais même à bilbao avant
d'aller à madrid gras bilbao avant oui
sylvain dewalle oui d'après d'accord
dont vous avez une minute pour conclure
monsieur marchait bien je pense que
cette émission est intéressante
les questions qui m'ont été posées par
les journalistes m'ont permis au pas de
charge évidemment mais ça passe vite
quatre quarts d'heure une heure de faire
le point de faire le point sur
l'ensemble des questions alors
il ya une question n'a pas été posée que
vous aviez évoqué dans votre
présentation
c'est la santé du parti communiste
français eh bien j'ai évoqué l'odeur des
problèmes qui se posent ils ne nous
échappe pas ces problèmes
beaucoup de problèmes ce qui serait pas
naturelle c'est qu'il ne se pose pas que
des communistes ne se pose pas de
questions quand ils doivent participer
au gouvernement et à la majorité alors
qu'ils ont vécu 58 en plus même dans
l'opposition ce serait anormal que les
communistes nos électeurs ne se pose pas
de question quand nous avons opéré ces
mutations profondes dans dans notre
politique dans notre stratégie dans
notre façon d'aborder la construction du
socialisme
notre conception du socialisme dans
notre conception d'un nouvel
internationalisme c'est à dire le
rapport avec toutes les autres forces
les partis communistes et ouvriers mais
aussi les autres forces parti socialiste
parti démocrate chrétien que les
communistes ne se pose pas de question
ce serait une anomalie
il est normal le parti communiste
français est en mutation profonde
seulement je veux dire ceci voilà nous
avons une bonne politique
nous venons de tenir en grand complet
c'est pas un achèvement parce que il ya
des choses qui vont continuer de se
poser des problèmes et il va falloir les
résoudre mais le 24e congrès constituera
sans aucun doute une étape extrêmement
importante dans l'histoire et dans la
vie du parti et c'est pourquoi vous avez
parlé de santé du donneur j'ai dit que
ma santé était excellente mais je dis
que la santé du parti aussi est bonne oh
ça sans doute nous n'avons pas obtenu
les résultats mauvais que nous avons
obtenus nous avons perdu de l'influx ans
ça nous a fait mal et ça nous fait mal
et nous pensons tous et nous travaillons
tous à la remontée de notre influence
mais j'ai une confiance extraordinaire
dans cette remontée
et je vais vous dire pourquoi c'est
parce qu'il est un critère qui en fin de
compte est toujours décisif en toute
circonstance ces critères de la pratique
or maintenant les français
moi on avait dit je communique son
gouvernement vous aurez plus aux
journaux lendemain matin vous aurez pas
de pain vous serez au journal
vous serez dans les camps de
concentration genre et j'en oublie et
des meilleurs les gens ils s'aperçoivent
que les communistes au gouvernement ils
ont les journaux ils ont dû paille etc
bon il ya des problèmes ne sont pas
résolus mais enfin ils s'aperçoivent que
le l'apocalypse qu'on avait prévu n'a
pas eu lieu et il nous voit maintenant
sur le terrain avec notre politique
seulement ils ne nous voient pas assez
et c'est ça mon adresse aux communistes
ou le camarade
il faut croire que les gens nous voient
plus tels que nous sommes avec notre
politique est que nous soyons actifs à
la mise en oeuvre de la politique vous
dire ce soir ce soir les français vous
ont vu georges marchais alors c'était
l'heure de vérité prochaine invité
jacques chirac le 24 juin bonsoir
[Musique]